quelles aides maupin correspondant de
rtl états unis c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soit un bon soir
qu'elle aime maupin merci d'être avec
nous on dirait avec sur rt france tout
d'abord quelles sont les derniers
développements nouvelle nuit d'émeutes à
craindre aux états unis dans plusieurs
villes ce qui se passe dans les selles
oui c'est historique nous avons vu des
bâtiments dans la chine tonnes proche de
la maison blanche qui ont été incendiés
dans presque toutes les grandes villes
les gens descendent dans la rue il y à
des affrontements entre les manifestants
et les autorités
c'est une crise nationale tels que le
stationnement jamais vu certaines
personnes comparé à cela avec après ce
qui s'est passé après la mort de john
martin king junior
nous avons entendu des rapports selon
lesquels des manifestants ont été visés
par des tirs à dans leur ville mais on a
beaucoup parlé de morts 2 policiers et
le bilan humain commun de personnes sont
mortes les médias traditionnels aux
états unis ne remplissent pas leur rôle
ils ont été mort des manifestants sont
morts et leurs médias n'en parlent pas
en 2d trans concentre plutôt sur
l'idéologie
les médias de ruches parle de racisme en
moi à droite on pas un peu l'anti
fascisme et d'autres dans l'arche east
mais on ne parle pas de personnes qui
sont mortes il ya des vies américaines
eut perdu
et pourtant les médias ne s'y
intéressent pas aujourd'hui quel est
votre regard justement sur cette crise
vous dites légères les états unis n'ont
quasi jamais connu ça la faute à quoi la
crise sanitaire
est venue s'ajouter à la crise sociale
très important nous avons des petits
emplois c'était sûr beaucoup
d'américains jeunes notamment et les
autres aux américains n'ont pas un
emploi régulier
ils ont des petits jobs des petits
emplois ça me travaille pour hubert pour
l'hiver où ils n'ont pas de les contrer
à long terme travail quand ils le
peuvent
l'un d'entre eux n'ont pas de travail et
beaucoup ne sont pas comptés dans les
statistiques du chômage
ils sont cons ces choses et travaillent
ils s'inquiètent pour la facture le voit
se faire tuer dans la rue effectivement
on va faire le point de munitions c'est
l'explosion dont jean mon travail soit
conscient de chez eux et ont filmé les
gens sont en colère
on a derrière lui son intégration et se
retrouve là quelque chose de nouveau ou
de vin et sein de l'institution
stationnaire qui normalement et est ce
un jeune officier de police ont
également été conciliant car tout le
monde sait qu'on est vraiment au dessus
de la barre de touristes posent
énormément à l'autre
quels que soient leur ton conciliant
effectivement le baril de poudre a
explosé moi jamais entendu parler
d'émeutes
dans l'ombre haskell ou dans le canton
natis partout dans le pays ce sont des
émeutes au niveau national auparavant
c'est dans toutes les régions c'est
vraiment de tous les côtés vu de
l'extérieur
donald trump lui semble en tout cas
c'est ce que nous disent dans les médias
ici en france notamment semble attiser
le feu avec des tweets incendiaires de
notre âme qui répondait de façon
sécuritaire qu'elle est justement la
vision de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
de cette politique de donald trump à ce
qu'il lé jugement du juge et elle est
sévèrement jugée par dont effectivement
largement critiqué cette politique
lorsque de mettre à twitter mais qui
commenceront le pillage nous commençons
à tirer c'est là si c'était beaucoup de
colère cela n'avait pas du tout quelle
est la situation c'est un fait une
aggravation
cela a tellement peur la situation peut
plus donald trump
parce que leur attention antifa soient
considérés comme une organisation
terroriste joue avec la peur
nous avons effectivement starisation
sont les antifas de droite ou d'extrême
droite
bon je voulais mais le constat de la
nuit est par contre l'extrême droite ou
le mans surréalisme
manifestent contre la police et contrer
le gouvernement l'institut fait raciste
et comme ce n'est pas gentil faire qui
est un jeu c'est pourtant deux épreuves
c'est un qu'il s'agirait plus complet
que tous ces protestants sont payés par
les libéraux sont extrêmement dangereux
bien sûr qu'on se demande au gouverneur
de reprendre le contrôle de la situation
de la grille mais qu'est ce que cela
veut dire
la sculpture extrêmement effrayante
beaucoup de personnes soutiennent les
manifestants mais là je n'en sais pas
plus pacifique or était elle-même
incendie il ya également beaucoup de
rumeurs disant qu'il y aurait des agents
provocateurs et qui ne savait pas grand
mystère mais plutôt de certaines sa
fuite et qu'il y avait des travaux la
situation et de justifier les
répressions très forte de voies très
différentes s'élève même à l'orangerie
les médias traditionnels se concentrer
uniquement sur ses avis cours d'eau gist
les faits on les oublie on laisse de
côté
merci en tout cas là bas m'ont pas un
correspondant verte et aux etats-unis
nous d'avoir apporté ce point de vue sur
la situation